let me welcome you to another one of our
free 45 minute webinars this one is on
somebody who I think many people are
familiar with and a text that often gets
taught and then looked at pretty closely
and then put down as we move on to so
many other things but it's really a
wonderful short of philosophical
dialogue very rich Plato's symposium and
I wanted to look at the themes not only
of love and and sex in terms of desire
and sexuality and gender but also some
of the implications for politics in this
work that I think you have to call out a
bit and we'll probably talk quite a bit
about this in Q&A section so I'm Greg
Sadler those of you who know me this is
all tattoo for any of you who don't I'm
the president of reason al so I'm a
philosopher you could say in private
practice that's our company through
which we offer these sorts of webinars
and online seminars and tutorials and
all sorts of other stuff that I can tell
you about later I'm an online educator
on figures in philosophy I've actually
taught Plato's symposium not only in
face-to-face classes but several times
in online classes as well that I've
designed and I've been teaching Plato's
works in particular for about 20 years
he's kind of a staple figure of mine
and so I'm very happy to be be talking
about one of the texts that I actually
like the best which is the symposium so
what I thought we would do in this
webinar is we'll do a very very brief
introduction and again you know anything
is a fair game in the Q&A so if there's
anything that you want to know more
about just just ask about it make a note
for yourself the topics that we're going
to discuss in this fairly short
compressed format are the structure and
themes of Plato's symposium and then
we're not going to look at all of the
speeches I wanted to look at three
sections in particular the very early
section with Phaedrus and Pausanias
speeches
Aristophanes very famous speech about a
seeking or other half and then finally
the wise woman do demos discourse and
then we've got 20 minutes reserved for
Q&A and discussion and sometimes we go a
little bit over in that which is quite
all right so think about some key
questions that come up for us these are
really existential questions meaning
that in the course of human existence
these pose themselves to us and we get
into lots of discussions and we were
given answers that may not always be the
best answer so one of the key questions
is well what is love and then we we have
another set of questions is it something
good or something bad
some people think that love is actually
something we want to avoid is love
connected with sexual desire and how is
it connected is it the same thing
something different is it overlap and I
should point out to that that here in
the symposium the word that Plato is
most often using is eros which we often
associate just with sexual desire but it
had a broader meaning not only for the
ancient Greeks but also for Plato
another question is love or sexuality
need to be limited in some way or
controlled or directed is it a force
that can cause all sorts of problems for
us and if it is then how do we do that
and you know to either of these love or
sexuality sexual desire have anything to
do with the political community or is it
something where we should say well
that's private life and then we have
political life and they're not really
connected with each other so Plato
discusses these really never showing his
own hand until the end with the speech
of do Duma by placing a lot of speeches
in the mouths of people in the dramatic
context of a symposium a drinking party
so we're going to talk a little bit
about that you see a nice little
depiction here of people laying down on
these couches to drink and enjoy
themselves so let's talk
about the first topic what what is this
symposium business it's a really weird
drinking party and I've done some some
you know talking about this other in
other places and videos that I can give
you as a resource if you're interested
it's a drinking party where instead of
drinking they talk instead and they're
going to give speeches and praise of
love and so we want to look at those
those speeches and the order of the FEM
so let's talk about symposia in in
general so a symposium means coming
together to drink you know it's coming
from the the verb for drink and then the
swim that that is a prefix meaning
together or with and these were quite
common in ancient Greece you know more
of an upper-class sort of thing in part
because you had to have a significant
outlay for the wine and there would be
entertainment and food as a matter of
fact they they send away the
entertainers in this case there's a
flute girl who's supposed to play and
the reason why according to Plato they
decide not to drink very heavily
although they if you read all the way to
December they're all drinking by the end
if you read that you're going to find
that it's because they're hungover at
least some of them from the celebration
from the the night before it looks like
we may have a some some mic issues going
on hopefully everybody is hearing me
well so what they decide to do instead
of doing heavy drinking and they do this
on their doctor's orders Erick's amicus
as a medical professional who is
involved in this decision is they're
going to give speeches and they're going
to give speeches about something that
hands not then eulogized up until that
this time and that is love the the great
God the force that moves us this you
know thing that we all have to take
account of at one time
or another they're celebrating Agathon's
he's the host his victory in the recent
tragic competition he's won a prize and
you'll see why if you read his section
quite a great so each of these um
speeches is is given is given in praise
of love and it's interesting because
they're supposed to be praising this
this great God who is you know worshiped
in in various ways who's who's
celebrated and each of them is is
complaining if you read the things about
the others not actually getting around
to telling us what love is that they're
they're flattering love but not actually
praising love each of the participants
in this is giving a speech praising love
now some of these people are actually
lovers and and this is an issue we can
talk about in the Q&A in the symposium
you're going to see a lot of references
to male male relationships and they're
they're quite often one that involves an
age and to some respect to power
imbalance so Pausanias is an older man
who is the lover of Agathon who is this
beautiful you know brilliant youth who
writes writes poetry and and personís is
an older legal expert of some sort
eric's amicus is this physician and
Phaedrus is another young beautiful man
as well each of the speeches that that
we see here and we played it actually
tells us well these aren't all of the
speeches and these aren't exactly what
they said but these are what what I
remember from the time he's putting this
in the mouth of another character each
of them expresses a certain point of
view so Eric's amicus for example looks
at things the way not just a medical
doctor but somebody who's devoted to
Natural Science would do it Aristophanes
tells us a crazy comedic story
you know Socrates in his term is going
to engage in dialectic Agathon is going
to engage in rhetoric and each of those
speeches addresses one or more that came
before them as well here's the order of
the speeches as we have them if you
haven't read the text first this guy
Phaedrus gives a nice little speech it's
fairly short and it's rather
conventional and then Pausanias follows
up and gives a much more involved speech
that has to do in large part with with a
moral philosophy and with legal issues
Eric's amicus gives a really interesting
although rather dry speech if you look
at the the way it's everything is framed
it's very scientific Aristophanes then
who is supposed to speak right after
Pausanias but who swapped places with
Erickson McKay's was going to give his
speech and it's like I said this this
wild story about what the gods did to us
and why everything is the way it is in
terms of love and then we have a bit of
a well we have Agathon speech and to put
in there as well
but then we have Socrates speech and
Socrates is going to do something a
little bit strange he's not going to
speak on his own behalf he's going to
attribute it what he has to say to this
wise woman do Duma and so we're going to
take a look at what she has to say and
then it comes to a common conclusion
with this guy Alcibiades who is supposed
to be Socrates lover but is really in
love with Socrates and he's totally
drunk he's sort of the golden boy of
Athens at the time this is before his
fall from grace for betraying his
country and moral perfidy and all sorts
of things like that and he is going to
give this wild speech that turns it into
back into a drinking party now we want
to look at Phaedrus and how sanyasis
speeches in part because
they have to tell us something about
politics and how it might be connected
with love and one of the questions we
want to keep in mind is do they actually
teach us what love is this is going to
be a complaint a little bit later on so
let's take a look first of all that
these two together both of them are
going to discuss love in some respect
Phaedrus is going to praise love as this
ancient God or force and as the source
of our highest good he's got this
wonderful metaphor or maybe better not a
metaphor but a proposal for an army of
lovers as a very tough military force
that's not really that serious of a
speech Pazhani as' gets us to something
a bit more serious in terms of proposals
he he begins distinguishing between good
and bad love so he introduces a
distinction within love itself and he
discusses the laws and customs of the
Greek city-states pertaining to love and
he notes some inconsistencies there so
here's here's some of Phaedrus key
points right love is the source of the
human beings highest good he says and he
says that there's no greater greater
blessing than love and it works both
ways to the developing man the beloved
youth then a generous lover you you have
this older person who takes you under
their wing because they love you they're
attracted to you they open up
opportunities and to the lover then the
beloved youth there's so this is kind of
a viewpoint that makes this private
relation of erotic desire something that
is the highest good and notice the other
things that that Phaedrus contrast this
with he says family or rank or privilege
or wealth these are good things but
they're not as good as love and why not
why are they not as good as love they
don't guide a person to what is actually
best what is best according to Phaedrus
is the better life and this is one
that's focused on honor in the eyes of
the lover this is going to lead us to
the notion that the
the you know love is going to bring out
the best in us not just personally not
just privately but also politically it
could be used to keep us on the right
track in society in military operations
you know the reason why he says we
should have these armies of lovers is
because they they're going to be afraid
to look bad in each other's eyes
Pausanias is going to say well that's
good but we really need to make a
distinction here we need to be more
realistic about love not all love is
good not all love leave this to the
better things as a matter of fact we can
talk about two different Aphrodite's the
goddess of sexual desire there is a
heavenly for you reign in love who is
not the product of the sexual act born
from the heavens themselves and this
leads to love of the mind or the soul of
the other person then there is what he
calls panda Mian or earthly this is the
other Aphrodite who's the product of the
sexual act between Zeus and Dione so
what he's doing is he's playing off of a
attention with in Greek mythology itself
between the origin story of Aphrodite
and this earthly love leads to love of
the body the one of them is good and the
other one is actually if not bad at
least kind of all over the map
it could turn out to be good it could
turn out to be bad it's not predictable
so love of the mind is the the good type
of love he also has this really
interesting discussion of the the legal
systems in the Greek city-states that
that have to do with regulating
relations of love between these these
older you know fully mature men and
younger men or sometimes even boys and
he says there ought to be a law against
loving mere boys and it's not based on a
notion of exploitation or something like
that the way it might be for for us you
know when we talk about the age of
consent he says the reason why you
shouldn't do this is because their
character is not yet clear they're
they're underdeveloped right and you
know you don't want to throw
good time and resources on the
potentially vicious lover and then he
talks about the differences between
these different Greek people's I mean
it's kind of a typical you know the
Athenians are right in the middle
between the the heart to you know under
sort of refined but weak Ionian Greeks
and then those crude rough Greeks and
the North who you know aren't very
articulate in the north there's really
no legal regime and anybody does sort of
what they want in terms and so a lot of
it is really not not it's driven by
erotic desire but it's not a consensual
relationship they rule it out altogether
in iyanya because they're under Persian
rule on the Persians don't like freedom
and don't like all that sort of stuff
and and pause Anya says the the
Athenians have it more or less just
right but there's an ambivalence there
in Greek attitudes about male male love
and he points us out with many examples
on the one hand it's felt to be
something good but then again fathers
try to make sure that their sons aren't
being brought into these sorts of
relationships so maybe it's not good and
you know the the younger lover often
gets made fun of by his peers so it's
clear that there's something on the one
hand that they view is good but on the
other hand kind of shameful and so
Pisani has a proposal here he says the
law ought to distinguish between the
good and bad lovers we ought to leave
the good lovers alone that is those who
are going to love the other person for
their mind they're going to cultivate
that it's not primarily about sexual
attraction or if there is something like
that going on it's in terms of
attraction primarily through the
personality and then we ought to
restrict the other you know pandemic
that you know the the earthly
lovers from from consummating their
their relationships so those give you
some interesting political aspects to
love
then we have Aristophanes speech and i
think it's worth mentioning here that
many people attribute this to Plato as
his own position so they think that
Plato himself is advocating what it is
that he's putting in the mouths of
Aristophanes that's not actually the
case
Aristophanes was a great comedic
playwright and he is is telling a kind
of you know silly story that's supposed
to have a deep meaning here so the
mythological account and I'm going to go
through this very quickly is that human
beings were originally different than we
are originally what we perceive as an
integral person you know with with two
legs and two arms and one set of sexual
organs and one head and you know all
that that sort of stuff was just half of
a human organism instead we were these
round creatures that had four arms and
four legs and we're old all over the
place and and we're very powerful so we
became a little bit too big for our
britches and you know try to take over
and the God said we got to deal with
this so Zeus cuts all of these but he
actually has her faceless to it
he has human beings cut into halves and
this leads to all sorts of problems it's
supposed to be a typical comedy stuff
it's supposed to be a solution to a
problem and it leads to other new
problems because you know these these
halves go wandering around trying to
find each other and they don't really
want to do anything they they start
dying off and the gods like who's going
to worship us who's going to give us our
sacrifices so they they fix it by by
straightening out the design by moving
the genitals around to the front and
this allows as Aristophanes is going to
say this allows for reproduction in the
pairs where it was a male and a female
together they can you know reproduce and
continue the species and in the case of
you know male male or female female they
can at least like you know get it on and
and then get on with real work now that
they're no longer being driven mad by
sexual desire oh and the human condition
for Aristophanes is that we are speaking
the missing half of ourselves or at
least something sort of like it because
maybe the missing half died of' so if if
our missing half was somebody who is who
is male then we look for males if it was
somebody who is female and we look for
females interestingly this sort of
radically reverses the priority of what
we nowadays call heterosexuality over
homosexuality we tend to look at
heterosexuality in our society as if you
know that's you know the heterosexuals
are the males were really male and
they're attracted to females and the
female who are really female and
therefore are attracted to males and
Aristophanes says no no they were
androgynous they those those pairings
were originally you know male and female
together and so he actually you know
frames them and quite unflattering ways
they tend to be adulterers and
unfaithful wise again remember it's
comedy here and then there's you know
people whose original composite was two
females and those are female homosexuals
who desire you know other women and
similarly with male male has they they
desire men here's where it gets
particularly interesting in terms of
politics but you know Aristophanes
doesn't talk much about the female
female coupling but he does talk quite a
bit about the male male one and there's
sort of a defence in their of their
activities he says the cause for their
behavior is that they're actually hyper
masculine they are more masculine than
the men who seek out women they they're
attracted to masculinity in in their
lover they're attracted to these
features and they're lovers of their
beloved and he says if they show real
manliness and public life which means in
the political sphere that means that he
thinks that these people are in some way
better suited for politics than are you
know what we nowadays would call so
heteronormative
people right and so there's an
interesting reversal going on here he
also notes to that there's no natural
desire to marry and produce children on
the part of these men but they'll do
that because of the custom of society so
that you know they can continue on with
with what it is that they're supposed to
be doing what are some of the other
implications so these are the people
that he thinks are the ones attracted to
and suited to political life it could be
in part he doesn't tell us a lot about
this but it could be in part because you
know the people who are attracted to the
opposite sex are going to form
households and and you know focus on the
domestic sphere rather than on the
public sphere and what we want to think
about is how desire plays out in this
sort of arrangement and whether the kind
of old boys club that he seems to be on
the verge of proposing would be a good
or useful arrangement for political life
should we have a class of people who are
so to speak disengaged from from their
their domestic life in order to realize
this this political you know what we
call it management of society together
as as sort of a shared good or do we
want some other sort of relation it
seems like Aristophanes is actually
proposing this as a public good when we
go to look at do tema who is of course
the the teacher of socrates speech we
get a very different kind of account so
Socrates tells us that he's not going to
give a speech like everybody else and
this is typical Socrates right I'm you
know use the guy who gets up in front of
everybody and says unaccustomed as I am
to public speaking of it of course gives
a great public speech so he told us that
he's going to he is going to talk to us
about what he learned about love from
his teacher when he was a young man this
teacher is an older woman do Duma this
this priestess this wise woman and she
provides Socrates
with an initiation into the mysteries of
love but she does so in a rational way
and I'm not going to talk that much
about you know all the ins and outs of
this I will do that more these longer
intensive seminars but she does say that
we have a desire for immortality and
love is really in love and sexual desire
are really about producing something
that will in some way be immortal we
don't realize this we think it's about
you know getting it on and getting off
but really it's about leaving something
behind and she talks about people being
pregnant in the body he or she has mine
men who are looking because you know
there was there a sort of a conception
back then that the child is actually
coming from the man through the seed
that's being planted and the woman who
then carries it obviously the biology is
a bit off but we can see what she's
talking about metaphorically here those
were pregnant in the body they want to
have sex which ultimately produces
children and they do this in part
because whether they realize it or not
they want to leave these children behind
as replacements animals do this even
plants do this and the question that we
should ask is whether this really gives
you any sort of lasting immortality or
whether that's it's just sort of a
fruitless desire that just reproduces
others like us and with it its own new
desire there's other types of
immortality she says so here she
discusses those who are pregnant in the
soul or the mind now notice that she
doesn't say they just go around and find
some raw material and work with that
instead they find partners who can
appreciate what they're doing and she
talks about the poet's and we you know
we have to think about people who
produce great media products she's
talking about Hesiod and Homer and how
they produce great works of poetry that
that stand the test of time we're still
reading Homer today we're still in much
less reading Hesiod
some of us still do read Hesiod and
we're still reading many other great
works of literature as well so there's a
kind of immortality
that's tamed through that through the
production but she goes on and here's
where a political dimension enters in
she says that lawmakers and statesmen
produce even better children which our
laws and societies and institutions and
she brings up Lycurgus and Solon these
these you know great lawmakers Solon for
Athens like her goes for Sparta as prime
examples of this then she also talks
about this latter of love the idea in
the symposium is that at the very end we
can ascend through a kind of following
out our erotic desires and purifying
them in light of contemplation of what
makes the things desirable moving from
the lower to the higher and we start
with single beautiful bodies it's
interesting that that you can't skip
that step you have to be attracted to
other bodies first and we start to note
what makes them beautiful we start to
notice commonalities and then we we
start to move to the beautiful soul in
the end it finishes with the beautiful
itself the form of the beautiful or the
form of the good which we're not really
going to talk about here because you
know if you're contemplating that you
don't pay much attention to anything
else what's most important here is that
the lower is dependent upon the higher
and so love of a lower beauty can lead
us through to a higher beauty so love of
the beautiful soul leaves a leads us to
the love of beautiful activities customs
and laws we say the beautiful soul is
made beautiful through these and and so
that's a higher love we move from the
personal to the impersonal love of these
things act you know activities customs
and laws leads us to love of the
knowledge that that guides them and
makes them possible and for Plato in
each case we're getting to know what is
more real and more valuable so we we
move from the you might say realm of
private erotic
desire to the public sphere that that
that you know makes the individuals what
they are at least opens up the
possibilities for them and then we move
from that where we're in the realm of
politics itself to the realm of
knowledge there's a movement from the
practical the active to the
contemplative so are there implications
for for politics in this you know Plato
does think we're shaped by the kinds of
political regimes we live and develop
within and the question that we should
ask ourselves is whether our
possibilities go beyond those of our
society or whether we're just
conditioned by it and and the answer for
Plato is that we have to make an effort
to go beyond those that our society is
giving us so the way in which we
understand desire and love and relations
to each other has some important
implications the other question is does
society need to be transformed or
changed or protected and if so who is
qualified to do that and towards what
ends how did how does love or this is
you know transformation of erotic desire
figure in here maybe not everybody for
from Plato's perspective ought to be
calling the shots in politics or culture
maybe it's just the people who have
developed to a certain extent and but
notice that this development is not just
a cognitive development but an affective
development the development of our
desires of the things that most
fundamentally move us this is in a
certain way a very optimistic view that
that Plato is enunciated here about our
capacities for making emotion and desire
serve us in some way so now we have
plenty of time where I'm a little bit
over time but we'll take up some time
with a Q&A you can you know unmute your
mic and ask me the question or make a
comment that you want or you can write
it and I'll see it in the chat window
and I will respond to it
all right so mark writes one could argue
the end of life is contemplation and
ordering one's actions towards this end
mean one has a chance of fulfilling
one's nature and thus being happy so
yeah I mean that I think that is plato's
take that the highest happiness that we
can enjoy is through contemplation and
it's contemplation of reality as as it
truly is rather than how you know we
often portray it to ourselves so there's
there's a cognitive transformation that
goes on there moving away from being
directed to some things that are semi
real to things that are more real it's
always a bit difficult to say what is
that going to look like you know and
Plato gives us some some interesting
metaphors about this but doesn't
ultimately tell us enough but you know I
think that that that kind of makes sense
given the nature of what he's describing
now the for me the more interesting
question is is it possible to enjoy
genuine happiness here in this life in
our personal relationships in our
political or social or I think for many
of us job engagements without you know
ascending all the way to this this form
of the beautiful the earlier speakers
seem to imply that that it is right
Pausanias and and Phaedrus and
Aristophanes the question is whether do
Dima thinks we can or not and you know I
think the answer is actually yes you
know when she's talking about the
immortality that Homer or Solon and
Joy's Solon reordered his political
community
and then they actually gave him a lot of
grief but in doing so the Athenians were
riven by status or faction and all of
them were pretty much out for their own
faction in doing so but he reordered the
Athenian Constitution and produced a
better more sustainable Society at least
for a certain point and I think he could
take great great joy in that sort of
thing kind of satisfaction and
fulfillment now you know I think Plato
would probably say that in some way
Solon was operating with you know
something like the knowledge of how to
do that and that contemplating that
knowledge is something that we can be
drawn to through erotic desire but
notice there has to be a kind of
transformation taking place with all of
this so that's a good question
let's take some some other ones
Michael Welch alright so we're in the
question answer period anybody have any
burning questions comments talking
points they want me to respond to well I
have a short question sure um I wonder
how exactly those Plato would envision
this latter happening you know moving
from the lowers could to the higher
stage of love yeah so there's a couple
components to it I mean he sketches it
out in that that speech that the oedema
gives and she she first like does it you
know sort of in long form and then gives
it kind of a summary form so it
definitely has this hierarchical
structure to it right
now the question is how do we move from
each stage to the next stage and she um
she says that we need some some other
person generally to to be our companion
on this to help us with it
and I think she's you know in that
respect that's probably right you know
there's the possibility of you know
that's discussed like in the Republic of
you know moving from from one level of
we might call one level of lesser
reality to another higher level of
reality and the similar thing is
happening here but even there there's
there's education taking place so it is
something that I suppose one could sort
of discover on one's own but usually
there's there's some sort of initiator
or guide along the way she doesn't go
into great detail about it precisely how
this is supposed to happen it's more
about what the progression is and she
does tell us that the lower
is is what it is because of the higher
so you know we can think about well what
makes a beautiful soul a beautiful soul
and we might have a lot of other answers
for that then then the autumn of
provides she gives a political answer
it's the the laws and institutions and
and the activities that people engage in
something that's that's bigger than them
and we you know we might we might have
other things that we make we think makes
a soul a beautiful soul or determines it
as a beautiful soul so it could be that
that we need a wider account if we're
going to try to have this this sort of
account but we don't we don't get from
Plato you know what would actually be
the practice Oh what would be like the
handbook that would get us from one
level to another
alright thanks sure
any other questions or comments or
issues confusions rants I got it
completely wrong who's he to talk about
this nonsense I mean I will say this a
lot while I wait to see whether anyone
else has anything to say what what's
really cool about this particular
dialogue is that it is so vivid each of
the participants is a different kind of
person and they have a different mindset
and they respond to each other so you're
getting you're getting a kind of
comparison and even conflict of
different ideas presented against each
other and then it's all brought to this
great conclusion this apex in do to my
speech and then like like any good you
know thing when you've got this super
high tension and we're seeing the
beautiful itself at least in language
suddenly Alcibiades breaks in and
everything goes crazy and he gives his
own speech about the nature of this
socrates guy at the end and Emin by the
end if you haven't read the symposium
you really want to by the end Plato is
bringing us to a question that he
himself grappled with in some of these
other works like the Republic for
example can the same person be a writer
of comedy and tragedy at the same time
if we want to expand it a little bit
more can the same person encompass to
the greatest degree separate approaches
to to reality and the answer that that
some people think it you know Plato is
not suggesting but but embodying is yes
it is that Plato himself is the person
who is able to encompass tragedy and
comedy and medical
courses and legal discourses and this
and that and and weld them all together
into some sort of composition so
Nietzsche actually interestingly thought
that Plato was in certain respect a
example of like pastiche of putting
together all of these different genres
that it now is he called shipwrecked you
know and so Plato's kind of cobbling
these things together so it really
depends on if you accept this sort of
notion that there's more there's a lot
going on in Plato maybe he's the
ultimate synthesizer of different genres
or maybe he's just a cobbler putting
things together in that that you know
we're essentially in broken form we have
another comment okay somebody anonymous
asks do I think
Aristophanes account is tragicomic well
there is a tragic aspect to it it's
primarily comic in part because you know
it's telling this this crazy silly story
and but but it is in a certain sense
tragic because it does imply that for
many of us we may not be able to find
our missing half right it's a huge world
missing half scanned I there's the whole
issue of like well you know if we were
cut in half a long time ago how do we
have missing halves now but but there
could be some some tragic aspects to it
max right so I'm not sure if this is a
can of worms to be opening just now but
do you think there's some correlation
between Aristophanes notion separated
beings help
however absurdly it was intended in
Young's canceled counts up to the anima
and animus the sort of male and female
sides of things and I mean Young is is a
one of the sort of really underlying
principles of Jung's work in general is
that we need when there's a duality we
need both sides of the duality and there
the sides are in some way connected or
attracted to or engaged with each other
so a lot of Jungian analysis focuses on
trying to work that out in particular is
there is there a correlation between
Aristophanes notion of separated beings
and what Jung is doing I know I guess
you could say there there is in a sense
you know Jungian analysis in part is
trying to rediscover to bring to light
to into consciousness what it is that we
lost sight of but that's still somehow
still there for us right and and it can
be a matter of finding another person
you know who were in relationship with
who we end up being compatible with they
respond to in certain ways so yeah I
think there could be some some
connections I mean Jung certainly knew
Plato I mean everybody everybody who is
everybody read the symposium at one time
or another and it's part of the sort of
common culture of educated people in his
day and you know that notion of looking
for our separate half has been extremely
influential like I said some people
mistakenly view it as that is Plato's
theory of love and they portray it that
way when really it's do to those
discussion that that gives us his theory
of love that sure wordplay to himself
got it from so alright are there any
other questions or comments we have a
few
we're overtime but I started a bit late
so they can take a few more minutes if
you like well if there if there aren't
any then what I will end with is by
saying that in in my view the symposium
is one of the greatest works of Western
literature and I focus in just a few of
the themes in the work but it's well
reading in its entirety and rereading
and rereading the person who I actually
got to spend a semester reading it in
Greek with himself had been reading it
for 40 years and when I asked him why he
kept on doing it he said that there were
still questions open for him in that
text so it's of such richness that you
can't really exhaust it the way most
classic works are so hopefully if you
haven't read it this will provoke you to
go and read it and hopefully those of
you who have read it already to reread
it and you know whatever you get from it
that's that's great
you will always be able to find yourself
getting more a rereading as I have been
preparing for this so thanks all of you
for your questions and participation and
I will sign off and wish you a good week
you